we're continuing our conversation with
Dave Rubin who is of course host of the
political talk show the Rubin report on
YouTube growing by the day I think is
fair to say so Dave let let's now turn
to we've sort of talked a little bit
about your political views generally and
I want to get a little bit to some of
the most popular questions as I
mentioned nearly 500 questions and about
50 insults that came in related to this
interview some of the insults directed
at you some of the insults directed at
me lots of anti-semitism to go around no
shortage of that ever but there are a
couple things that kept coming up okay
one is and I know you've heard about
this the criticism of your interviewing
style and as it as it generally goes the
criticism is there are people who go on
the Rubin report they say things that
are demonstrably untrue or at or at
minimum highly deceptive and Dave Rubin
doesn't challenge them so let me just
sort of give you the opportunity to
explain what your approach is and why
what underlies what some might perceive
as not challenging guests when when
maybe they deserve to be challenged
yeah well first can you give me an
example of that
sure so like for example when you had
David Horowitz on and he said Obama's a
communist and he did include it in a
sentence where he said a lot of things
that were untrue you could have I guess
conceivably picked out any of those
things but it was just sort of allowed
to slide where if you had a different
style you might have said can you tell
me what Obama has done that makes him a
communist in his legislation or whatever
the case may be I guess that's one
example okay so I don't so first off
David Horowitz saying that Obama's
economist that's his opinion of what he
thinks about Obama I don't know that you
can say it's actually to debunk Abell
though right you could say well if
someone is a communist there must be
something you can attribute to them that
would be communistic uh well I think I
don't I'm not David Horowitz his lawyer
or arbiter here but I think he would
argue that the policies that Obama put
in place like Obama care whether you
agree or not
or other thing or large taxes and things
like that that he would do goes as as
communist ideals let's say but anyway
putting that aside yeah my my interview
style by the way you know it's funny to
take questions I don't take question as
an interviewer I don't take questions
from my audience because I always feel
that it's it's better if these things
come from my head and also there's an
odd self selection so if you tweet out
you know I'm taking questions for Dave
or whatever you know mostly what you're
going to get is the haters because those
are the people that know I know Dave I
mean you know me well enough to know
that I mean the questions that I did not
even pay attention to or the ones that I
really think we wouldn't get anything
out of like as an individual I believe
I'm curious because your style is so
much different from mine your style
might be better I mean there's no rule
that your my style is better I'm curious
what your approaches in terms of style
yeah and believe me I'm not I'm not
accusing you of anything I just think
there's a there's an interesting we
always forget about this self selection
which is important because in a day in a
day of social media you only hear from
the screaming people okay I even see
this I even see this when I get emails
you know I get tons of email every day
people saying really nice things I get
people you know I get Muslims in Saudi
Arabia and Christian conservatives in
Missouri saying to almost the same exact
things to me and then you know but the
ones that stick out of my head are the
ones where people just telling me to go
you know ask myself or badly okay put
that aside my interview style I said
this many times is I believe that the
best way to interview somebody is to
really be able to hear what they think
and the way you do that is you listen
now when David Horowitz in this specific
instance when he said that communists
thing I was in that particular case I
was about to stop him but you're right
he then did quickly he like sort of said
it it was right at the top of the
interview he kind of smooth right into
something else and then and then the
conversation just went from there I do
remember thinking interview that I
wanted to get back to it but in the
course of an hour conversation I think
that one was almost an hour and 20
minutes you know sometimes something's
going to get a lot my belief is that if
you let people speak
you can either figure out if they know
what they're talking about or
I think one of the problems that we have
right now in mainstream media and you
know 10 guests in little boxes screaming
at each other and all this one of the
things that it's done is that it's made
it so that everyone talks in sound bites
I've done some of these cable news shows
I think you have even when I do those if
you know you only have five minutes you
gotta say things real quick and also if
you want to get booked again you have a
sort of say in a passion way and bubble
and over-the-top and all this stuff this
is terrible for for public discourse
it's terrible for the extrapolation of
ideas and it's terrible for for a real
dialogue that we should be having so my
belief is that if I sit across from
somebody and I really listen to them and
and listen to them say what they think
then I try to ask the right question to
figure out why they think that but my
goal is not unless I'm having something
that's closer to a debate which you know
two or three weeks ago I had Michael
Shermer who's skeptic and dennis prager
who's a believer in reality and god it
was it's what I believe it to be more of
a conversation than a debate because I
think that's just a more helpful way to
view it but my view is let these people
talk and you can tell but you can tell
because I don't think my audience is
stupid I think my audience is really
bright as I suspect yours is as well
when someone doesn't know what they're
talking about or when they believably
lie they will hang themselves you will
you can see it they will wrap the rope
around their neck and they will hang
themselves so I try to ask the right
questions to get the most out of them
yeah I mean I think this maybe it's just
a difference in approach right but like
I would imagine maybe you're right that
David Horowitz thinks Obama's a
communist because of Obamacare and taxes
but then I would say it might this is my
instinct you know I would say well what
taxes are you talking about and then it
would be like oh he's a communist
because he allowed the top income tax
rate to go from 36 to 39 percent I mean
it's like it so my interest would be in
if there's an assertion made that is a
what I you know I didn't know the
president was a communist that's
interesting how do you define that I
feel like we would get a lot out of that
you know and it's not it's just a
different
approach I think is what we talk it up -
sure
and that's listen I always say to people
people would say well I don't like the
way you do this really that I'm like
well someone forcing you to watch this
thing if you've got someone that you
like better than me watch that or if you
think somebody's a better interviewer
that that's I tip it this is just what
I'm doing I like it people happen to
like what I'm doing which is great but
yes you know by the way in that
interview I was really I thought we were
going to spend almost you know he David
Horowitz was a hardcore Lefty child of
Communists who was a lefty Berkeley guy
in the 60s who then evolved and now he's
sort of as hard right I think he's
probably he's probably pretty pretty
hard right maybe not diamond but
whatever is the next softest stone yeah
he's right no doubt about it
but my purpose of that interview he's
written many books of you know I had
recently done that video only a few
months before on Praeger about why I
left the left and why I don't think
liberalism has anything to do with the
left and print and Horowitz had sort of
been through that experience many many
years before has written many books
about it wrote an article about it
during Reagan's re-election so I really
wanted to focus on that so occasional
look occasionally something's going to
get by it's just how it is and by the
way you know my my friend and and who
I'm thrilled to call a friend and honors
a call friend and mentor Larry King you
know a lot of people used to say that
when Larry you know he's still doing
interviews now and I love him and I just
saw him last week yeah but you when he
was in his heyday let's say in the 80s
and 90s on on CNN a lot of people said
well he doesn't attack the people the
right way he doesn't follow up the right
way blah blah blah I I think my
follow-ups are actually pretty good and
I think as I said bye-bye
subtly talking to people you can get
them to explain themselves sometimes
into a corner if they don't know what
they're talking about but you know
everyone's going to have their critics
and I'm actually completely ok with that
and by the way maybe in five years from
now I'll look back and go oh I should
have done that a little different or you
know I you know everyone involved and
figures things out I think this the
quick rush to judgment I think is kind
of unfortunate but it's alright
hey I've got no shortage of interviews I
look back at and say what on earth was I
thinking that day but unfortunately I
can't redo those a lot of those people
don't talk to me anymore sadly now I'm
kind of kidding but no the certain
certainly
looking back and wishing I had done
things differently I think is a common
thing we're talking with Dave Rubin host
of the political talk show the Rubin
report on YouTube more after the break